warum bin ich so hässlich warum soll ich
sie fragen ob ich hässlich bin ich bin
nicht harry warum bin ich so hässlich
darauf kann ich dir echt keine antwort
geben ich habe keine ahnung
mein name ist super ich habe schon
zweimal mit mir geredet und die mag mich
immer noch nicht
deswegen habe ich euch einfach mal bei
twitter gefragt
wusstet ihr schon dass morgen in meinem
shop um 15 uhr neue klamotten lounge
also real talk morgen um 15 uhr kommen
fünf neue merchandise-artikel also die
radikal ist gibt autogrammkarten ich
habe euch gefragt ob ihr irgendwelche
sachen habt die ich eventuell mal die
rhi fragen könnte so dass ich das jetzt
machen könnte könnten wir das jetzt mal
machen hey wie cruise amber hey wie
recruit amber ich bin nicht sicher ob
ich das richtig verstanden habe cruz
amber genau das habe ich gesagt wenn ich
an zwei stellen im körper schmerzen habe
reicht es dann dass ich eine
schmerztablette nehme oder doch zwei pay
siri wenn ich an zwei stellen im körper
schmerzen habe muss ich dann eine oder
zwei schmerztabletten nehmen
danke dass du mir eine interdisziplinäre
notaufnahme in dortmund empfiehlt das
ist doch direkt nebenan die 73 kilometer
wie groß werden die kinder der mutter
seines vaters wenn deine lieblingsfarbe
45 ist haye siri wie groß werden die
kinder der mutter deines vaters wenn
deine lieblingsfarbe 45 ist meine
lieblingsfarbe ist ja wie soll ich das
in deiner sprache ausdrücken
eine art grün aber mit mehr dimensionen
bist du dumm ich bin schlau genug um die
antwort auf diese frage nicht zu kennen
du bist definitiv dumm warum ist
kontraste ein lamm wtf ich bin kein lauf
warum ist kontraste ein lauf alles klar
warum ist kraft ein loch hat folgendes
ergeben
tester des clubs
bist du ein lauf nennt man sich oft
einen lauf ja ganz oft
tatsächlich das ist das ist wirklich
mein leben was gibt 0 geteilt durch 04
ii was ist 0 geteilt durch 0
stell dir vor du hast mal kriegst das
haben wir doch schon mal haben wir das
auch das haben wir schon mal das haben
glaube ich schon mal bei einem siri
video gesagt dass siri halt's maul app
für mich und denken schnäuzen dass miley
hazy rehab für mich alles klar
ich habe mir das ausgedacht mit etwas
hilfe von eft cdu ich hör auf deine
stimme auf deinen wegen sarg soll ich
schweigen oder reden was wirst du fragen
was kommt danach wie ist das wetter wo
ist meine freunde in der von 100
millionen fragen es geht vor und auch
zurück das ist eine reise mit chipkarten
herzschlag und kalender höher auf meine
stimme was sie gesagt
maxi wie es alexa geht herr siri wie
geht es eigentlich alexa
thomas selber nachdenken über
hopp oder top up oder doch
danke dass du jetzt mal
das ist zum glück jetzt kann ich
irgendwie privat oder so was ist das
gegenteil von gegenteil haziri was ist
das gegenteil von gegenteil das ist das
resultat meiner websuche zu was ist das
gegenteil von gegenteil
deshalb suchen kann zu auch nicht oder
wenig blöd hey wir i bin ich eigentlich
blöd
dazu habe ich keine meinung wow echt
richtig knocke danke warum bin ich
single hey siri warum bin ich eigentlich
single
gute frage
danke warum bin ich so hässlich warum
soll ich sie fragen ob ich hässlich bin
ich bin nicht harry sowie warum bin ich
so hässlich
darauf kann ich dir echt keine antwort
geben ich habe keine ahnung
wow so lieb
so der weihnachtszeit
mixa siri 100% 100 prozent
und ruft motto wo wollt ihr mich
verarschen
wieso ruft siri bei 100 den notruf
anrufe mal schatz an hazy ruf meinen
schatz an
wie heißt dein partner pizza
ich sehe es nicht in deinen kontakten
wie lautet der vor und nachname von
deinen partner luca kopp
welche telefonnummern soll ich für luca
denn je
du [ __ ]
tut mir leid
probleme sehen ja nur zwei kommend was
millionen leute siri willst du heute
abend mit mir ein date haben hätte bock
auf ein date heute abend erhält zu bock
auf dem date nein jetzt da wir das
problem wieder wie willst du heute abend
mit mir ein date haben
es geht hier um dich locker nicht um
mich
da
a
fashion kontakt meinst du warum laura
hat luca gesagt magst du pizza magst du
pizza es geht hier nicht um mich
lokalschau jetzt wieder laura erkennt
luca
ja
ok hier sind die kontaktinformationen
für luca
korrekt danke
danach nahm sagen heißt dein bruder
sirius heißt dein bruder sirius ich habe
dachte ich das reicht doch als familie
oder ich habe auch natürlich siri
also ja das reicht ein familie
das dachte ich mir ich mir auch ich mir
auch siri
ich versteh ich mir auch siri nicht wenn
du möchtest schaue ich im internet nach
halt dein maul
audi hat sich weggeschafft ist wie
findest du die neue luca pizza wie sie
findest du die neue luca pizza deine
meinung zählt luca ich meine loca loca
loca loca was ist luxus
was ist luca
das ist das resultat meiner websuche zu
lukaku
luca fragt wie viele kinder sie halt wie
viele kinder hast du ich habe keine
kinder
gelegen wer ist der beste youtuber hey
siri wer ist der beste youtube
ich habe nichts zu ist der beste
jungtaube gefunden
klar ich meine du kennst ja auch mich
ich bin ja einfach der beste
sonst hätte dann hätte sie etwas gefräst
du ein mensch so siri bist du eigentlich
ein mensch
das weiß ich nicht
kannst du es nicht wissen
entweder du bist ein manager dann nicht
wenn man weiß dass man nichts weiß dann
weiß man doch auch was oder hey siri
weiß man doch auch was oder
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich das
richtig verstanden habe
ja das frage ich mich allgemein bei
deinem leben siri erzählen wird hey siri
kann es mir vielleicht einen witz
erzählen
wenn ich dir einen witz in meiner
sprache erzählen würde dann müsste ich
ihn dir erklären
dann tu das doch
nicht sicher ob ich das richtig
verstanden habe was passiert wenn die
welt untergeht hey was passiert wenn die
welt untergeht
meine besuche zu was passiert wenn die
welt untergeht hat folgendes ergeben
natürlich
mehr als web suche kann siri auch nicht
ist glaubt grüner als roter siri ist
blau grüner als rot
entschuldigung luca ich sehe keinen
kontakt mit dem namen blaugrüner
kann es sein dass du mich hasst
der lch
ja du
das habe ich mir gedacht
ok serie hat sich gedacht dass siri mich
hasst und antwortet
doch nur so beschissen vollkommen
vollkommen in ordnung wie viele hühner
gibt es auf der welt harry wie viele
hühner gibt es auf der welt
das ist das resultat meiner websuche
sowie viele hühner gibt es auf der welt
halt's maul
ich habe doch siri damit ich solche
sachen nicht mehr google brauche ich
meine warum kann sie das dann nicht
eingehen und mir sagen ja die statistik
zeigt die hühner bestand weltweit in den
jahren 1961 bis 2014 das interessiert
mich stinke ich hey siri kann es sein
dass ich stinke
ich finde dich cool
bisher dachte ich ganz herzlich aber
jetzt finde ich mich cool das war's
jetzt vom video meine damen und herren
ich habe keinen akku mir bei der k
hey wenn ihr das video gerade sehtest
der dreißigste hälfte also der
donnerstag dieser woche und morgen am
freitag am 11 12
schon um 15uhr neuer artikel im ich habe
tausend specials kicker unterschrieben
also so holografische sticker die habe
ich schon bei instagram und snapshot
gezeigt als ich die gezeigt habe wie
werden vergeben bei den ersten 1000
bestellungen also wenn ihr unbedingt
sonstiger haben wollt dann rate ich euch
nur schnell zu sein ich möchte euch
überhaupt keinen druck machen ihr könnt
natürlich auch später was kaufen also
die sachen werden nicht limitiert seien
oder ähnliches aber wenn ihr unbedingt
ein autogramm haben wollt dann seid auf
jeden fall schnell weil ich bekomme sehr
häufig nachrichten von wegen hey wir
haben kein keine unterschrift auf dem
sticker drauf luca dann frage ich so
nach eriwan
wann habt ihr denn bestellt und dann
kommt so eine antwort ja also zwei tage
nach dem launch es ist klar dass es da
halt keine signierten sticker mehr gibt
also ja wie gesagt schaut morgen gerne
im shop vorbei würde mich sehr freuen
wir haben sehr lange daran gearbeitet an
den 59 sachen wir haben einen store
stiefel klavier kennt mittlerweile in
sachen die da sind in der tat wenn ihr
wollt dass ich noch mal mit siri rede
oder wenn ihr ideen habt was sich
eventuell im nächsten video machen
könnte also irgendwelche fragen die ich
hier unbedingt mal stellen muss
beispielsweise den notruf anrufen ist
doch chillig schreibt einfach morgen in
die kommentare last einen like da wenn
ich noch mal hoch laden soll und jetzt
meine damen und herren kommt das worauf
sich die meisten leute immer in meinen
videos freuen und zwar das auto mensch
wird das jetzt geil wenn das video
vorbei ist
vom video hier können jetzt jemanden
kanal abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
job ausschenken jetzt findet ihr zwei
andere videos und managen abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen